How many moves did you come up with,
David?
>> So, I was able to do
the problem in 11 moves.
I won't talk you through
the entire process, but
if you'd like to pause this
video you can take a look and
see the exact moves I used,
and see if they match yours.
We know that 11 moves are the most
efficient way to solve the problem, but
these aren't the only 11 moves that
can actually solve the problem.
>> Good, David.
That's the correct answer.
So now that we have solved
this problem together,
next time you go to a cocktail party,
you can entertain all of your guests by
showing how you can do this problem so
effectively and so efficiently.
Even if all of them flounder trying
to do things on their napkin that's
not succeeding.
>> So we've not yet talked about how
an AI method can determine which states
are productive and
which states are unproductive.
We'll revisit this issue
in the next couple lessons.